hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jesse I'm Jesse today we're gonna
do some work with react and I must start
out the stream by telling you a little
bit about my morning so far just because
it was out of the ordinary so if you
notice I have a tie which I don't
normally have so I thought that I had a
presentation today and I was going to
present this site that we've been
working on to all the like the vice
presidents and the heads of all the
departments of the school and I thought
that the meeting was going to be early
like it was gonna start at 9:00 a.m. but
I didn't know where it was so I thought
wow I need to get up early and get in
here early so I can get everything ready
there were still a few more things that
I wanted to do to the site before I
presented so I got up at 5:30 a.m. and
got on the exercise bike and started
making some updates to the site then and
my oldest son was actually up with me so
I ended up only doing a little bit of
work in the morning and then he and I
watched YouTube videos and for the rest
of my workout but then I got into work
at 7:30 a.m. which is which is pretty
early for me I never get in before 8:00
and I was working and working and it was
almost nine o'clock and I'm texting my
boss like hey where's this meeting at
and he finally texts me back and says oh
it's tomorrow
oh so the good news is I have more ready
than I thought I would before the
meeting and I have you know more time
now to get things ready so that's cool
I'm gonna meet later on today and kind
of go over
a little bit more about like what
basically about what the people that I'm
going to present to are looking for so I
can make sure I give them the right
information but anyway I said is what it
is kind of like I wore the outfit I
wanted or where to look professional
today so I don't know what I'm gonna
wear tomorrow
but anyway that I guess so I've been
doing a few things to the site I'll go
over them just really quickly and then
I'll check out the live chat as well
before we start so I guess the most
technically challenging thing that I did
and it's still not very challenging but
the most technically challenging thing
is that we have different logos now
depending on screen width so we have
this more narrow version of the logo and
then it comes out to the full version so
I just did that with the built-in hidden
components that material UI has so this
is in the app bar component if you want
to check it out everything in github is
up to date so we're all starting at the
same point and I'm gonna start up
let me start our bank drop - before I
forget so y'all can check this out as as
I'm going over it and I'll put this in
the live chat oops
I don't have my screen up sorry anyway
let me do this again so when we go like
this the logo changes we pop it back out
and it goes here so that's that's what
it did sorry about that and then I
changed this
in the background-color I got rid of
that purple that we had that was just
kind of for demonstration to make sure
it was full with and let's see I added
in some some more cards with a Lum nigh
profile and a faculty profile and so we
went out some of those fairs and then I
merged in a pull request from Harshit
that fixed some of the errors that we
were getting in the car I should say it
warnings that we were getting and also
fixed some issues we were having with
client-side routing that I wasn't even
aware of that we weren't getting the
proper behavior with client-side routing
because of the all the custom stuff we
were doing with routing so if you want
to check that out that's the last pull
request that was merged in there was a
lot to it so if you can go through I'm
not even go through at all and in this
dream because it could easily take up
you know a half hour just going through
it all but I appreciate that and some of
the other things that it did do was
harsh it fix this little hover so we get
the correct color and I'll have to also
do the same thing here so I'm just gonna
have to look and see what he did and
let's see that I fix I think I changed
size and positioning of some things up
here so a lot of little things nothing
huge hearts should also did some work
with the the cards to make them look a
little nicer I still want to try it
looks like right now everything just
goes to two columns with some of these I
think are too big like obviously these
profiles like are getting just huge so
might want to see about extending this
to three columns at some point instead
of just two but it does look a lot
better than it did there's not as many
gaps okay
so today Sood I was working on oh sorry
I said I was gonna check out the live
chat first let me see what's in the live
chat and then we'll be started hey josh
says it's first time he got the first
comment in its first time here so
welcome thanks for coming in is here hey
Emma let's see if somebody god so love
24 says hello I'm brand new a coating
just got to the dedication page product
for HTML
alright cool welcome if you're just
starting out there may be a lot that
we're doing that may be a little bit
beyond where you're at you know and
you're learning so feel free to ask you
so many questions as you can and totally
understand if you know maybe you're not
there yet and really don't want to watch
that's cool too I'll do my best to
explain as I'm going on hey a lot of
other people saying hello Christopher
you are not too late the live coding is
about to start
Michael says the even gooder news is
that you can go to dinner tonight and
look like an adult
I actually I can't but my son has a
karate class so probably not wife will
be there because I don't think I'm gonna
be home early enough to take him but I
guess I will look alright Emerson said
at least you're looking good today yeah
let's see
let's see Christopher brown says YouTube
video on page is overrated try using
custom video player I'm not sure which
which you mean Christopher so let me
know Lawson at 3 says shout out to my
nephew Robert he's a 12 year old
aspiring programmer all right awesome
Robert that's really cool you your
programming and twelve years old so keep
at it and I'm sure you'll be if you're
not already programming better than me
you probably will be if you keep keep up
the learning alright okay so that's
everything right now that's in the live
chat I'm gonna start my my Pomodoro
timer and we're going to do 25 minutes
of some coding and be working in react
today after the 25 minute timer goes up
I'm going to take a little break and go
back to the live chat answer any
questions that you have
let's see also want to invite everyone
if you happen to be on Instagram check
out you if you want check out my
Instagram profile there's a link to it
if you go to my youtube channel that's
linked in the description I have my
links to all my social networks
Instagram will be on there
I think it's Jesse I go is my name but
anyway I put coding stuff on there too
and I also announce when I'm going to
stream and I do on Twitter as well so if
anybody's interested you like to watch a
stream or like the kind of stuff that
I'm doing that's just kind of another
place where I I put some info all right
so let's work on this top
let me scroll down quickly actually
let's let's do that this is what I was
going through making sure that we're
getting we have these set to the right
sizes see cuz I kinda I don't want an
image like this to be very small so
let's go back here and change that while
I I see it and before I forget
there we go
for now that'll just make it look a
little bit nicer
and yeah so we're not really it's not
like this is the finished version of
this or anything but if I do go to show
a larger version you know on a larger
screen tomorrow then at least there
won't be gaps all right so let's look at
this section here so what I'd like to do
and I'm we have been going kind of
mobile-first with everything but I know
that in my presentation they're probably
gonna want to see the full-screen
version even if nobody asks I know my
department had at some point is gonna
say why don't you show them the full
version so I want to get this cleaned up
a bit I think that we could do without
some of the space here and we could cut
down on the space between these just a
bit by a few pixels add more space and
here lino saw better so there's a lot of
alignment things that I think we could
do yeah we can we definitely do some
better things with that and that'll be
the first thing that everyone sees so
I'd say that's that's worth spending the
limited time on that that we have before
tomorrow's presentation well Christopher
Brown did clarify about the video since
you're using a YouTube video on the
website rather than html5 video player
which you can create your own style
controls for the video player which is
better than embedded YouTube video yeah
we had thought about doing that I it's
still possible we've done that on some
other sites i popping a youtube video in
here was just the easiest way to get
something up on the screen to see how it
looks so I'm still open to doing that
the only thing I'm not sure about with
the videos is and this is what I like
about YouTube videos let me know
Christopher if if there's something
similar we can do as well with using the
html5 video
is for YouTube it will automatically
scale the video resolution based on you
know the user and what their connection
is capable of can I do that somewhat
easily with the html5 video tag and you
know what would I need multiple versions
of the video and if I go to switch video
- I need multiple versions of it every
time because these videos are gonna
switch out and the the people who are
going to be switching them aren't really
going to be video people or coders so
taking into account all of that is there
way we could use the video tag instead
of the YouTube embed to accomplish the
same thing and still be as user friendly
if there is a way and I just don't know
about it I'd love to know about it
because we could definitely get a nicer
UI I don't like having the big red
YouTube button right in the middle here
it's not really part of our color scheme
let's see okay so let's go into your
check first of all let me make this
bigger this is probably hard for
everyone to see I'm gonna try to shrink
this as small as I can and still keep
you know what we can we could probably
make this bigger let's just pop it up
fullscreen there we go I kind of like it
here like really small and then that way
I'll know for sure whether I'm making
this too big and it will overlap
anything so first things first this logo
I think could be a bit bigger but you
know what maybe we oughta try to shrink
this first before we mess with the logo
and then that that way we'll know how
much space above and below that we're
working with that seems like that maybe
that'll be the more sensible way to go
about it
all right so the first thing I do want
to look at it these options because I
think I I just put too much too much
padding in here where am I even getting
the padding at huh
that's a
hmm
maybe the sketch that changed
I thought I had this setup differently
at some point maybe I was mistaken
okay
all right see what we have here I
definitely think that we can take this
padding off of the top so having top
zero whoops you know I don't I don't
want it off of here so let's get rid of
it on here just put it on this outlet
there we go so that removes a bit of
space in here which is exactly what I
wanted and that looks good so let's go
over to the code now and find where I
need to put this style in line for that
to work
and you should be in the app bar
component
oops
oh you see this is where I did the the
logos we just use this hidden component
so the the logo that's just fu s is
hidden on medium and up and then the D
logo that is the full Franciscan is
hidden on small and down just ended up
being pretty simple once I remembered
that this was an available component
alright so here are all our social media
icons so down below that will be the
menu that we're trying to to change okay
our menu item okay
call them to bottom let's check out that
class call them to bottom display flex
okay so that is this display flex center
Center and okay great so if we put this
padding top zero on to here then we
should be fine and since we're just
putting a number an integer in here we
don't need the quotation marks oh yeah
okay so we've gotten rid of that style
we just put in dev tools and you could
see should we wait a second
we may need to
let's give it a refresh and just just to
verify that that style is not working we
need may need to make that an inline
style then
yep so it looks like our padding-top
zero is being overridden by this so we
could do we could put important here but
I don't want to go too important that
should be like the last thing that you
try everything else doesn't work so
since this is coming in a style tag this
style tag evidently is being inserted
further down the page than this one
that's why it's overriding this one so
it's also possible that this one is just
more specific so if you see this just
selects the class but this selects the
class two classes right so the class
that's the child of of this class so
specificity could be an issue here as
well but in any case we can without
resorting to important we can definitely
make this work if we just make it inline
so let's go back to our code we'll take
this out so we don't need it there and
then we'll go down to our actual
component and I know that this component
is huge right now like this whole entire
thing so eventually this will be
refactor and everything will be split
out into their own components so I just
don't want anybody to think that we
would like to leave a component like
this because we won't but sometimes
before things are finalized it's just
easier to work with it in one place I
find if I start to refactor too early
sometimes I'll end up the leading
components that I don't need anymore
that I could have saved time and never
even made them so on this grid item
we're gonna add a style tag or style
attribute and we're gonna put in double
quote or double brackets which means
we're gonna go into JavaScript first
right with that first bracket and then
the second bracket is since we're
already in JavaScript the bracket just
means a it's an object alright so we're
going to pass it
the script object and it will be
padding-top we can okay suit and then we
can put the zero and let's close that
out so now when we save and check out
our website we should see that as an
inline style and it should override
whatever else was there and we can see
let's give it a refresh just just to
make sure that's not anything left over
from what we had there we go so here's
our padding top that's showing up in
line and that overrides the only thing
now they could possibly override this
style is if we were to put important and
that's okay so since I did it like this
that still leaves that possibility open
later on if I'm if I really need to have
something apply then I still have that
option of using important so that's
that's why we don't want to go straight
to using important if we don't have to
because then you you don't leave any
option for yourself or other developers
if they would like to you know change
that then you know they're really
limited that they have to go in and
potentially change more than they would
like to all right but anyway just just a
few CSS thoughts from me so that's a
little bit smaller okay I like that I
think I think that's more reasonable in
terms of height it's probably still a
little bit taller than I would like but
we you know we have two rows here for
our content so you know maybe we could
shrink this by another few pixels but I
wouldn't go more than that at this point
because it will get too jumbled so I
think I'm gonna leave that for now as is
and we can always go back and try to
shrink it up more if we need to so since
that as is here I do want to if I can
quickly decrease the space here I would
like to do that but I need to figure out
where where we were actually getting
that
let's see okay I was just checking out
my timer see how much time I have so in
about eight minutes I'm gonna go back to
the live chat and answer questions so if
you have a question in there right now
just please be patient for a few more
minutes and and I will get to your
question
so I'm trying to figure out where this
this gap is coming in if you could see
the gap that's right here and then maybe
I'm missing something but why
and we're not setting the width of this
element anywhere nowhere here we don't
have any margin we have no padding set
for that side I mean we do have text a
line
Masaki the chat really quickly to see if
anyone sees anything that I don't
all right I'm just gonna start going
through some of these and seeing if
anything okay all right so if we get rid
of this display:inline-block that
definitely that's an effect but it also
gives us a lot more space up here as
well
and I'm pretty sure that we added this
in for reason so I'd rather not break
something
hmm you can shrink things up a bit if we
get rid of that line height
okay umberto saying is there an outer
container for those using something like
flex yeah I mean here's our container
with Flex which because of the delay
that's what I'm probably seeing it
before you're seeing it then Qatar
Rahman then then Qatar Oman I'm sorry if
I'm mispronouncing your name I'm trying
to trying to sound it out anyway they
say can you check the box model on the
Ally yeah let's check computers
but we did have something Warbucks
yeahit's guess it's not gonna matter
either way
hey Nikki how's it going
this this is probably unrelated but it
kind of bothers me that there's no ul
for these allies I don't know how that
happened but it seems to me that these
should all be inside of the UL right so
maybe we could keep the grid here but I
guess we just we didn't put them inside
of UL because we created these hat bar
menu item components which I haven't
looked at that component for a long time
yeah so these are all just allies so we
really should be putting this in a ul
I'm just kind of wondering you like
would it mess up screen readers and
things like that if we if we didn't have
this
and I don't really know the answer to
that but we have kind of more proper use
of the HTML tags and it's it's not gonna
hurt yeah it is all right yeah so that
definitely did mess things up let's
let's see if we can switch this there we
go
okay so if we just move the all this
flex stuff down one to our ul and then
that helps all right
so let's let's do that I'm about out of
time for this Pomodoro session but I I
think we're it in better shape here by
adding the UL and so the last thing I'll
do before we go - before I go to live
chat answer some questions is I'm gonna
put this class down on the UL
see where that gets us okay
yeah that's not bad we can work with
that all right let me set my timer then
for five minutes and my phone is buzzing
a lot I just want to see if there's
anything important water's being turned
off on campus but not in my building all
right okay
and my wife is messaging me also I don't
think it's an emergency all right I'm
gonna scroll up just a little bit and
it's not too much in the live chat so I
may be able to get through it all we'll
see you never know sometimes I talk for
five minutes just about one question
Oh Harshit says that he can watched live
today because tomorrow is a school
holiday cool cool that's awesome
Harshit is there some other time of day
that we could do the livestream that
you'd be able to watch or is it just
going to be too much for you when
schools in session because I'm pretty
flexible we could try to do this a
different time if you want but I totally
understand if that's just too much and
you can't do the live streams because of
school and I don't want this to detract
at all from your studies but let me know
if there is something I can do to help
it be you know easier for you to watch
if you want to today's at school all the
day for my kids so they didn't have to
go to school today which is why I could
come in early so I didn't have to drop
them off at school / beli asks what the
best programming languages in 2018 I
don't know if I could answer that I
think it just depends on what you have
experience in and what you're trying to
do
I can I can say I think this is a very
reasonable thing to say that JavaScript
is probably the most versatile
programming language right now because
you can do client-side and server-side
programming there are ways to program
you know robots with JavaScript VR a are
native apps you can use electron to make
you know desktop apps there's just a lot
that you can program with JavaScript so
it's JavaScript the best I don't really
know it's what I like to use and you can
do a lot with it but that's I don't
think that's a question that's you can
answer easily so hopefully my answer is
okay but I mean I know it's not really
an answer to the question but that's a
good answer that question is beyond me
how should ask did you read the notes in
the last PR attentively I don't know if
I'd say attentively I looked through all
the code pretty attentively but maybe I
did not read it as attentively as I
could I often go back and read through
more attentively because I know there's
there is more that I need to do so I did
read that part that there's a lot of
stuff that needs change now I didn't
have time though before the video to
change those things
okay so Christopher Brown if you
remember from earlier in the stream we
were talking about ways to present
videos in a webpage and we're talking
about YouTube embeds versus the video
tag and so Christopher said you can do
different resolutions for different size
devices and pixel densities with source
set however Christopher is not aware of
a way to do this with network speeds
okay so I guess I'm gonna stick with the
YouTube embeds for now because I really
like that we can take into account a
user's network speed I don't I want to
avoid to things that that are a bad user
experience so on the one hand you just
put in high quality video and you people
without a good network connection you
know have a lot of buffering it doesn't
play or people have a good network
connection and it just crushes their
data right so I don't want that but then
the other extreme is okay well let's
just put in really low quality videos so
we respect people's data usage but then
everybody gets you know this degraded
user experience because they don't can't
get the high quality videos so I don't
really see it I think it would be
difficult to find a way between those
two extremes if we go with using source
set with the video tag since it's
already built in and it works with
YouTube embed we do have to live with
some limited functionality and we can't
customize it completely but but in
exchange for that I think we're giving
the users a much better user experience
we're also giving them the option to
like save our video for later so you
know if we go down here the video I can
share right from here so we have the
sharing right there we don't have to do
anything extra to get that we can save
it for later which i think is a really
nice feature
and then that will also direct users to
our YouTube channel for more content and
that all comes built in so there's
definitely trade-offs the embed is not
for every situation the YouTube embed
but if you can get away with it and that
your client is okay with having some
YouTube logos going on on their page you
do get a you know a lot of advanced
functionality you know basically for
free so that's what we're going to use
for now I do appreciate the suggestion
though and if we can yeah if there were
another way to do it I you know I'd
definitely be up for it okay it looks
like my timer did go off here but let me
look I'm almost to the bottom of the
live chat all right so we got we have a
vote for the YouTube player San Bay says
you look it's a misspelling but I'm
assuming it meant to say you look good
and if that's what is what you meant to
save and thank you I tried to look good
I shaved like this little top part of
the beard you know and under here I
combed my beard like I tried to bet I
didn't have my presentation today but I
guess I look alright for YouTube
okay so I'm going to when I come back
I'm gonna start within his question so
any questions do you enjoy being a
developer and so that's what we'll start
with when after we do this next Pomodoro
session let me see the time okay yeah
we're definitely only gonna do one more
session we might not even do a full
session so basically since I came into
work so early I'm gonna be at the point
where I put in all the time I was
supposed to put in today really soon but
then I also have a meeting later and
then so I have two meetings later
back-to-back so to avoid me going over
my normal time I'm gonna take like a
break so after this stream I'm going to
work on the coding challenge that I was
working on over the weekend so some of
you saw on my channel I need a live
stream Saturday morning well it was
Saturday morning Eastern Time so I'm
gonna go back and work on that
I may even stream that on my channel if
anybody's interested I think I I came
close to a solution but I don't it was
not the best way to do it so I might
just change the whole thing but it needs
to be done before Thursday so anyway
that's why I'm not gonna do a longer
stream today so I'll kind of take a
little break work on that and then when
it's time for my meetings oh I'll go to
those all right so let me get back to
we're working on ok I just kind of
messed this up so do we have these
little yeah we have these little disks
here text-decoration we need
text-decoration on here as well
so I kind of work now I need to put them
on the El eyes now it's list I wasn't it
yeah I don't know why I sent text
decoration list-style-type:none there we
go okay so that you oneís
list-style-type:none we popped that you
owe in let's go up and put it in our
class might not be a bad idea to rename
this class
let's do this
menu lists lists outside none and that's
gonna get rid of that little that disk
or that circle that comes right next to
all our list items so I don't know if
you could see it on on your screen but
it was showing up as white it was hard
to see but if it happened to overlap
another letter before it then you could
see it and now we need to change this to
menu this down here I think is this will
make this naming will make more sense
that'll be easier for me and anybody
else working on this to tell what we're
talking about then you list let's save
that and verify that it did what we want
looks like it awesome so I'm gonna
refresh yeah
all right that looks good now we're
gonna do some work in dev tools just to
get the spacing looking good so let's
put some padding around these a tags
that'll give us a larger click area so
let's do padding I want to do padding
let's say zero so we want top and bottom
to be zero but then left and right to be
four pixels
okay so you got four pixels here and
then if we go up to the L eyes and we
put padding zero for pixels okay that's
too big
gives us a gap yeah I think this was the
gap that we were working with before oh
nice a bonus from what happened is we
now this is not lined up vertically in a
much better place here with with the
rest of what we have so that's nice okay
I'm gonna let me know in the live chat
what do you think that this is too much
space am I losing my mind here or what
to me it just seems like too much space
if I drop that down to two pixels is
that more reasonable I kind of like that
okay so it looks like more space is
better so it looks like you are okay
with that
okay I'll flip it back back up so this
gives us like sixteen pixels space we
have four on there a tags and then four
on our allies so that means between
these were four four four and four which
is 16
okay all right I'm okay with that if you
all think it looks fine because I'm
going to point an hour I've looked at
this for way too long like I mean I've
been looking at variations of this for
literally months now because we've kind
of been working on this even before we
started working on the rest of the site
so I don't think I'm in a place right
now or I can look at this you know
and in the right way you know definitely
no with fresh eyes okay all right cool
so let's add these on so we need to add
it to the a tag and we need to add to
the Li so that means we're going to be
in that component we made for each of
those items that app bar menu component
so we have our list Li and then for a
class name and then their ul link what
was I thinking when I came up with these
class names I mean I guess it makes
sense but I'm just not sure why I said
ul link would we say padding:0 for and
then we're going to do the same thing
here the reason that I'm not putting all
the padding on one element is because I
want well I want two things I want to
have a larger click area so if you see
that the area you can click actually
starts before you even hit the text so I
want that larger click area it makes it
easier to click but then I also don't
want click areas right next to each
other so you accidentally click the
wrong thing so by using half the padding
we want on the LI and the other half on
the a we get both so we have a little
bit extra so we have four pixels all the
way around that extends further than the
text to click but then we also have four
pixels all the way around here which
means we actually get eight pixels right
so four for this Ally and four for this
Li of space between so you see as I run
my mouse over you can see the cursor
changes so there's an area where I'm
clicking right now and nothing's
happening that's that's good that's what
we want
oops okay that's why I did it like that
now I want to see if we can decrease
this space because one since I did this
I added this ul and you can see this ul
comes in with all of this margin at the
top and we definitely don't need that
and we probably don't need any at the
bottom either so let's get rid of any
margin for this so we do that with
margin zero wonderful all right this is
what I was I was wanting in terms of the
look for this top app bar you know you
can't make it really slim if you're
gonna have two rows of content but this
is about as slim as we can make it I
think and still leave enough space for
everything to be readable and clickable
all right great let's add that on to
that ul then in our code so we need to
jump back into our app bar and go to
this menu list up at the top here and
let's add our margin zero okay and the
last thing that I want to do up here I
would still like maybe to see this be a
little bit more slim as a button but I I
don't want to nitpick right now hmm
that's interesting okay this is kind of
it let's see if it doesn't when the
screen is larger okay it doesn't alright
so there's going to be an odd situation
where if the screen is narrow enough
it's gonna drop down like that I don't
like that I'm gonna leave it alone for
now I'll leave it alone for now in the
hopes that maybe we could get this we
could change this name or yeah yeah I
don't think it's likely to happen but I
know not everybody that kind of has a
say in this really likes the title being
faith in life right here so there's a
chance that this might change so I'm not
gonna try to fix this if it's gonna
change all right so the last thing I
want to do up here is make this larger
so let's see where we have okay so right
now it's just controlled I believe by
this max height 3 or M let's see three
point one three point five okay
yeah so I actually I don't want it to be
I don't want to do the height on this
this is changing the height I believe
for more than one section and let's see
what happens if I add an height 100
pixels all right that max height is so
overriding header image but I could
change the max Heights area
all right so with it being this large I
just want to see if we I see so if we do
make it that large then at some point
we're gonna squish all these what just
happened that's weird
okay so let's let's go here and then we
can really see at what point I need to
stop making that bigger so let's go
excite pixels so I definitely don't want
it to be on your pixels but I thought
I'd just start there Wow 48 this is the
largest I can make it
all right see how 48 looks we make it
bigger uh I think I'm okay with 48 and
I'm okay with that for now let me know
where did that go
I think I lost it when I was moving in
and out whoops
huh so that was already what we had
anyway huh so this is actually what we
had exactly so I guess we're keeping
that yeah it really only looks small
compared to the height we have on this
and the amount of white space we have
above and below so I don't like that I
think I just wanted to have less white
space but I mean I I suppose that I
could just use a media query so that
once we get down here then it starts to
get smaller
yeah let's try that let's see if we can
use choose a media query to change the
max height and make it
let's try 80 pixels of course if we do
that we need to also change this just
right now where we're setting this
height all right so we need to we need
to change two places
let's do that now before I forget
alright so in our app bar I should have
our image our header image and in our
header image we can let's grab this
media query and just reuse it now this
is kind of the a different way to do
media queries it's not going to look
like what you used to it with regular
CSS but since this is a JavaScript
object we're going to do things
differently and I lost there it is we're
gonna put a comma remember this is
JavaScript objects we need commas
between all the items here but then down
here we're gonna say and small and down
so in this case we don't want small and
down we want large and up so I think
that should give us what we want we want
large and up and we want that to be max
height 80 pixels and let's copy that and
set this on the menu button I'm not 100%
sure this is the right one but let's try
it was set on the menu button and we'll
make the what was at the height the
height 70
okay now we'll save that and see what
happens all right so it's it's large
right now we have that height 70 okay we
have the media query showing up great so
right there right where we wanted it it
changes awesome awesome right and we're
actually on just by me kind of
eyeballing that it was only by a pixel
or two you can see just very slight
movement so I'm not even gonna try to
make that precise because who's gonna
sit here other than us and go like this
to see the difference okay nice that
header is looking like it's looking like
it should look I still think that this
icon here is a little bit off the the
vertical alignment is off so wonder how
we can correct that if I do
[Music]
oops there we go
wonderful okay so for all these items I
had padding-bottom of eight pixels so I
just added the same padding-bottom of
eight pixels to this and that'll work so
let's just do that
now in our app bar menu item whoops
that's not it so we put it in I think we
have it actually in this component so on
our SVG icon the class name is search
SVG so we'll add it there search SVG or
is it at a show kind of sushi clothes
search SVG there we go
padding-bottom eight pixels save it
great alright
cool I'm I'm actually I'm pretty happy
with that right now this is yeah this is
probably the nicest that this app bar
has looked so far
all right I'm happy enough with this
that I'm I would I would present this at
my meeting so I think we're I'm gonna
stop messing with this now to leave time
for other things
let me check how much time I have left
here all three minutes okay let's just
do a git status here see what we've
changed get add and we're gonna do a
yarn yarn cm okay that's gonna help us
walk through this commit message so uh
nice let's do a fix and say it's gonna
be a just item spacing whoops ad j ust
just a boy I was facing okay that's
pretty much what we did right yeah okay
hopefully we pass all the linting and
the tests and everything and then I can
push that to get up and everything will
be available
awesome
okay cool I'm gonna go to the live chat
now and answer all the rest of the
questions so if you have a question
please put it in the chat now and I will
do my best to get through everything see
how I am on time okay good
yes so like I said after I end this
stream I may take a little break and
then I'm gonna work on another
JavaScript problem on I'm gonna
livestream it on my channel so not on
the free code camp channel on my channel
if anybody's interested that's going to
be its it's not react at least not yet
it's just plain vanilla JavaScript I
mean it's it's node so it's JavaScript
on the server side so I'm just working
through a coding puzzle just with
regular regular JavaScript so if you're
interested come come join me there on my
channel about I don't know maybe about
15 minutes after I finish up here okay
I'm gonna scroll up I know I said I'd
start with his question okay so in ass
do you enjoy being a developer I I do
enjoy being a developer so there are
some parts of being a developer that
aren't that great
but I don't think it necessarily has to
do with being a developer it's just I
don't know work situation so trying to
think if there's anything developer wise
that I don't like hmm I really I like it
I like building things I don't even mind
that much when they don't work it's kind
of to me like like a puzzle
I try to figure out where the bug is I I
guess the part that I don't enjoy a lot
of times is like at the very beginning
of a project trying to think about how
I'm gonna do the layout more of the
design side of things
that takes me a long time
so it's and that part I'm not really
doing a lot of coding I'm just doing a
lot of thinking and searching through
other websites there's fine inspiration
so I don't know that part it's kind of
weird for me if it takes a really long
time I don't like it but if if I kind of
get on a roll with an idea and it starts
to work then it's really fun but
otherwise I like it the part the part of
my job currently that I don't like as
much as I'm not a big fan of all the
meetings
I don't mind meetings if they're like
like video chat
meetings because then like I'm still at
my desk I can still you know like
looking's up on my other screen if I
need to when you're at a meeting it's
it's kind of rude to be working on other
things like in person when you're out a
meeting but a lot of times I attend
meetings and there's a lot of stuff at
the meetings that doesn't pertain to me
at all so that just kind of like is
mind-numbing sometimes also it sometimes
it depends on who you're working with
you know you get a client that has a lot
of really strong opinions that aren't
necessarily the best practices that can
be tough and that's not that's not
really fun to work with a client like
that but otherwise I do I do like it
okay I had asked hard [ __ ] earlier if
there was a time I could stream that
would be better and says now it's you
know it's 12 hours between between us
here so okay well that's too bad hard
[ __ ] I really appreciate you being in so
many of the streams and helping out and
so I hope you do really well with your
studies though and we'll still be
working on projects together then cut
says a new do stream so welcome thanks
for watching how did you get your your
work to let you stream also why did you
move from tomato timer to pom-pom
so all these for the second question
first because heart should also already
answered in live chat and he said
because pom-pom is made by me yes so
harsh it made the pom-pom timer and as
he says it is a dark theme and I love
dark theme stuff so so that's why I
switched yeah when I should said hey I
made this try it out I tried it out I
liked it so so that's why I use that and
for getting my work sorry huh
forgetting my work to let me stream I
just talked to my boss and said this was
before I was even streaming for free
code cam this was when I was just
streaming for on my own channel and I'd
get like one or two viewers sometimes
out of no viewers how but I just came in
one day and said I was thinking about it
and had an idea maybe I could stream my
work and it might be good for like maybe
the computer science students to see it
and maybe they might be interested and
want to come work on projects with us
and it'll help them with their
portfolios and it'll help us because
we'll have more people working on our
stuff and so my boss thought yeah that's
a good idea and then shortly thereafter
I was invited to stream for free code
camp and my boss thought that was a
really good idea
because it would be a lot of publicity
free publicity for the university
and also you know we have so many people
looking at the sights as we're coding
it's just you know you're gonna have a
better product like that and so many
times you all catch errors before I
catch them you make pull requests and
you know the projects are a lot better
because of you so anyway so my boss
realized you know right away that you
know this was this is only going to
benefit us my project roll with the
source anyway so it's not like we're
letting out secrets or anything but I am
I'm very grateful that that he lets me
do this and everybody my department is
very supportive of it
Christopher Braun says you can still
give them the option of selecting
different video qualities and then
loading the one they select yeah that's
true Christopher yeah we could we could
have them select the video qualities
yeah that's an option let's see
see and
okay um car says random question which
is best for post on spring boot rest
fetch or using Axios I prefer using
fetch I haven't really had much
experience with Axios so I can't do a
proper comparison between the two but it
just seems to me that you know fetch is
already built in like why not just use
fetch fetch to me seems really simple
maybe Axios has more things available
I denied use it and they're good
developers so you know maybe there's
something to Axios that I don't know
about that would make it better but you
know in terms of what what I use I I use
fetch and I always recommend fetch
Christopher Brown says why aren't you
using a separate CSS file we are for
some components and for other components
for not so it's nice for me at least I
really like being able to use the have
the styles right here so that there's
only one file you need for this
component so the component is very
reusable so I I like that I like to do
it like that when I can some places I
we're bringing in another CSS file and
the way the reason we needed to do that
is because we're importing some HTML
from that we pulled out of an old
database and we can't directly use this
you know the CSS that we're putting in
this javascript object we can't assign
that to places because we don't have
access to that like right here so the
only way that we could style that the
stuff that we're pulling in on the fly
is is to use a an external stylesheet so
so I guess the answers we are using it
just not in every place
so basically when we can get away with
not using a separate CSS file
we don't use one we put it right there
in the component in the component form
or reusability
Christopher Brown says here's a tip find
what whitespace feels good then double
it I like that I like that I've never
heard that but I will have to keep that
in my let's see nasrullah says how are
you I'm okay okay I was up pretty early
had some unexpectedly prepared I
prepared for a meeting that unexpectedly
wasn't happening today it's happening
tomorrow but other than other than that
I'm okay how are you doing
Christopher Brown says why not just use
margin isn't two sets of padding a bit
weird yeah I didn't think about that
until now and it's kind of weird I could
have just used the margin yeah you're
right I guess in my mind the way I was
thinking about it
lead the way I was visualizing it was
convincing these two separate components
and how much padding they would have so
when I went to write what it would be I
just immediately wrote it like that but
you're right it would have been the same
if I would have just put margin and
padding on the a the a tag so yeah
you're right either way it's the same
you get the same effect but in this case
we're adding an it's a it's the same
amount of lines of code to I suppose but
yeah I guess it might be a bit a bit
weird to do it like that
software death said I would match the
logo with the menu and make the social
icons smaller on top says react looks
neat though I've never used it before
new projects ok cool I think thanks for
the advice that let me check it out so
I'm not exactly sure what you mean
matching the logo with a menu but
definitely make this social icon smaller
we might go smaller I did decrease the
size a little bit from what they were
originally I might be able to go smaller
I'll see I mean maybe they just look my
screen makes everything everything looks
a little smaller on my screen than it it
seems like it looks on what I'm
presenting so I'll see how these looks
how these look what I'm presenting and
maybe I can make them smaller cuz I
really don't want to emphasize these too
much I'd rather have users click one of
these buttons than one of these buttons
so I may end up making this smaller but
I'm glad you said that because I wasn't
sure if if it would be too small
Nikki says how about a search bar
replaces the links went open that could
happen that yeah we could do that oh
yeah that's not going to be something
that I try to get done like today but
that that would actually work and then
it wouldn't matter how you know how many
items we have in here we still wouldn't
have to worry about it because anytime
that's open they wouldn't even be
visible yeah I like that idea what do
y'all think about that just when this is
open all this just goes away
and this covers everything
okay Joey says maybe use faith in life
with the with an ampersand instead of an
end yeah though that would actually cut
it down a little bit often saw that
stuff it's not gonna be my call
ultimately my boss is lefty enough to
make that decision but maybe I'll
mention it to my boss and see see what
he thinks
let's see Jim Jim mugs I'm not sure how
to pronounce that
Jim is a Jim alex gameplay alright Laney
Way says you can make a bar underneath
the menu in order to fix that problem a
bar
I'm not sure are you talking about this
problem where these stack on top of each
other
okay so Nikki saying the same behavior
that the search does on firebase Google
comm are this check
oh wow yeah that gets that takes up all
the space
interesting
okay let me know what you all think
about that I kind of like that hmm
see what happens when you'd say okay so
it hit make suggestions - okay cool
mr. Brown says you should try taking a
logo and cropping it so that the text
can be HTML and CSS it says and look a
lot nicer I am I'm pretty limited in
what I can do to the logo so I don't
know I mean assuming that I could find
this exact font which I have no idea
what font this is I mean maybe I could I
could do it but the way we like the logo
is pretty much set I can't change the
logo I just I put the logo in there so
I'm not sure if I'd be able to do that
or not
the cursor also says the social media
should probably be at the bottom of the
page having at the top is a bit odd and
removing the clutter would benefit the
overall design of the page yeah I could
see I could ask my boss about this I
don't like I don't even remember why we
initially decided to put these up here
so yeah that's that's definitely an
option so I'll see what my boss says if
he wants him up there obviously I'm
gonna leave him up there but yeah you're
right we don't need them up there we
could certainly put them in the footer
it's so Jim Alex gameplay says when the
onclick event happens on that lens a bar
should pop out underneath the menu more
stylish and fixes your problem so you
wanna click event oh okay so you're
saying that the search should pop out
underneath instead of scooting
everything over okay yeah that's another
option I have to think about that
all right harsh it's asking if I can
check out the messaging page for
JavaScript AF I can I'll take a look at
that after the after the stream
casue Brown says your page is slow
because you did the background
attachment fix currently this has
terrible performance so it'd be better
to use separate div with a background
and set the position to fixed okay cool
yeah actually
so whenever if I assume that you're
loading this then on with Engram so it
is slow on your machine because I
haven't noticed that it's slow on any of
my machines usually when I've used
background position:fixed as long as I
only use it on one element I don't see
any performance decrease if I use it on
a lot of elements on one page then I do
see it but I mean this the machine that
I'm on right now is probably better than
what most users will have so if if you
are actually seeing a performance
decrease then yeah then maybe I need to
do it a different way
Nikki said the girl's head gets cropped
have dev tools at the bottom okay Nikki
so I'm assuming then like your window is
pretty short then and
yeah with things like that I'm not I'm
not super worried about this happening
on a screen like this because no one has
a screen like this like they'd have to
shape their window differently for that
to happen so I mean if this happened on
a normal screen size I'd be more worried
about it off to check yeah you know what
it is even covering it up here that's
this is miss still isn't a normal screen
size but yeah maybe I will need to drop
this down a bit I haven't really worried
about it because I wasn't sure if I
would keep this image or not but we
could probably do like background
position wide drop it down a little bit
and then that would that probably worked
for most screen sizes
yeah
see my colleague Brian just reminded me
in the lab chat that there's a 3:00 p.m.
meeting today bring your laptop I will
be there
[Laughter]
same basis as a problem with a lamp
server as if we know some about it I
don't I don't know anything about lamp
servers
does any if anybody in the live chat
does please let let somebody know and
maybe maybe you can help them out
Nietzsche says use Axios recently it has
a lot of nice things built in and it has
better support without a polyfill for
fetch which create react tab has by
default okay all right cool so Niki
saying
Axios does have some other stuff
built-in which I kind of figured that
would be the case so I guess it's just
you know your personal preference or
what you have to do a lot of times I
just do basic things with fetch maybe if
you're doing something more advanced
Axios might be the way to go Harshit
says one big drawback I found using
fetch is you can't add eventlistener to
file upload progress okay that's that's
interesting so that actually is kind of
a big deal if you need that
functionality are says then you have to
use xhr and Axios is built with xhr so
it can easily do that I'm quite cool
Harrison says 34 year old father -
trying to transition to web dev
currently at Costco do you have any tips
my tips would be well I mean first of
all times going to be an issue for sure
because you're already working you have
kids I'm gonna say I'm I'm 32 right now
father of four so I understand the times
gonna be an issue but I would say
whenever you do have time work on
projects work on tutorials your best
thing that you can do to get a job and
web dev is to have a good
folio to actually work on projects have
them on github have a nice portfolio
site because that's going to be the
number one thing that employers look for
is you know can you do the job and you
prove that by your projects that you've
done so even if it's a side project do
that if you can get somebody to pay you
to do work do that too that's a great
way to learn I mean I used when I was
freelancing I used to take a lot of jobs
sometimes jobs that were they didn't
even pay that much but it was using
something that I wanted to learn more
about and so you take it you learn it
you know while you're creating something
and you make a little money and that
makes it kind of easier when you have a
family to justify spending that time
away from your family you know because
you are at least providing for them in
some way so and in cases like that I
just kind of saw myself as like I'm
doing a paid internship right now I'm
not making as much as I want to but I'm
learning so I would consider myself in
that position and mentally it just
helped me to to work through that so I
and I would say try to do a little bit
every day so if you can go for a half
hour or an hour of coding a little bit
every day is is good you know try to get
in like coding podcast when you're in
the car or you know if I don't know when
you're working out watch like a coding
video I used to hold my kids and you
know at nighttime they wouldn't sleep
and I'd hold them and I'd rock them
while I was watching something so you
can watch tutorial videos like that yeah
so just try to find those little ways
but if you do a little every day that's
much better than you know just saying
like okay every Saturday I'm going to
spend you know six hours doing it
because you know by the time you get
back around in the next Saturday you
will have forgot a lot of what you would
just learn so hopefully that those tips
will help you
I'm sure there's there's a lot of there
you know good advice out there but
that's what comes to mind
you're right away and certainly if you
can come back to the live chat ask you
know ask any questions that you have you
know I'd be happy to help and there are
a lot of people to watch the chat that
are you know more more advanced than me
that can give you some great answers hey
on LC how's it going
Jay Frederic says what about moving the
socialite comes to a position fix div on
the side I thought about doing that I am
I don't I don't really like to do the
div on the side the dip on the side
annoys me if it ends up blocking some
element on the page and sometimes that
happens now obviously if we were to do
the bit on the side we would do what we
could to make sure that that never
happens
but if I was going to move the social
icon somewhere I guess I'd prefer to
just move them down to the footer okay
so Jay Fredrik says the nav section is a
bit too crowded okay yeah maybe it is
getting too crowded maybe we should just
pull this stuff out I mean we could
maybe we could do a whole row right here
and just have one single row with this
access fus your kind of button here you
know in in its place here and just move
everything up to be where these social
icons were
you know we could try like I said I have
to talk to my boss before I make a
change like that but we would definitely
be able to get away with a much thinner
header which I like
I always like to have the the headers as
thin as possible
software dev says the menu in search box
should be bigger Joey says the font
looks a lot like spectral okay so I
guess we're talking about this one the
Joey says but then you would also have
to load that extra font just for the few
characters loading the logo might be
better for performance you know what I
didn't think about that but but you're
right yeah I would rather not have to
load an extra phone just for just for
that little piece God so love 24 says
yeah I agree with putting the social
media icons at the bottom we'll have the
search bar overlap the other tax law is
selected okay so move the social media
icons and then potentially have the
search bar just overlap instead of
pushing everything out of the way okay
okay so Christopher said it is actually
slow on a Samsung Chromebook plus okay
okay hard saying is due to end Rock yeah
that's actually that is a good thing to
keep in mind so we're going to keep in
mind that this is development build
nothing is menifee nothing no images
have even been optimized at all yet so
in production the images would all be
optimizing compressed we would be
running a lot faster because we'd be in
production build instead of dev dev mode
and instead of running things off of my
computer through Angra the servers are
going to be running on much more speedy
servers and yeah I think it'll I'm still
I'm still open and that's definitely
something that I'm gonna I'm going to
test because I don't want bad
performance through that but like I said
I've used this on a lot of sites and
I've never seen bad performance unless
I've used it more than once on a page
but I think that's something that we
should definitely test before we launch
on on old devices on different machines
and things and that just see like is
this something that we we definitely
shouldn't do it Ishta meets says why are
you using next yes when you could do
server-side rendering using pure react
and Express anode yeah well there's two
answers that question one next also does
come built-in with some other stuff
that's nice to have so although we are
doing a lot of custom routing with it
next router is nice that's not really a
big deal we could just use react router
if we're using like create react app or
something the other answer is I didn't
have enough time to learn how to do that
I've used necks before I'm familiar with
it and I know we could do what we wanted
but
if if I would have had to have taken the
time to learn how to do server-side
rendering properly with reacts I I never
could have made this as a deadline so
the deadline for this was supposed to be
the end of this month now it's gotten
moved back not because we weren't ready
but you know just for other reasons that
had nothing to do with the coding so if
it's going to get moved back a lot then
we certainly would have had time but
based on the time frame that I had for
this site you know I I had to save time
where I could save time and next is a
nice a nice way to do that do
server-side rendering without really
having to to learn a lot about it it
just works I would definitely like to
know how to do it without having to use
necks because sometimes I think next is
overkill for some little things that I'm
doing that I'd like to be server-side
rendered so that's going to be something
I'd like to learn how to do at some
point but right now there's too much
work to be done Michael so since you
since you're going to be showing this
you might want to delete two of the
footer columns three makes it super long
on mobile yeah you're right the I have
three columns here maybe I should just
put in the actual content that will be
here that won't be too hard to do so
we'll see depending on how much time I
have I'll do that I don't I guess I
don't really need to scroll the way down
but that that's actually a good a good
thing to do I mean yeah maybe I'll cut
down the text significantly and then
that way if I don't have time to put the
real content here then it will look
nicer so I like that idea Michael
our Harrison said thanks yeah I get a
again a 4 a.m. get up at 4:00 a.m. to
code okay cool so Harrison was the one
that was talking about changing you know
careers into web dev yes yeah I find
myself waking up earlier and earlier
just to have a little bit of time like
do a workout sometimes I code and so
yeah I understand that
our shits gonna leave AC arch I know it
started to get late there it's a Tuesday
already started alright well thanks
thanks for coming a lot chatter they
appreciate it Christopher said you
should try aligning the mission summary
div to the left and maybe confine it to
the width of the video below it's yeah
I'm not sure what I'm gonna do with this
yet I kind of want to mess around with
font sizes to make this bigger so it's
supposed it's supposed to be a break a
clear break between this section in this
section so I like to keep it full width
now keeping it full with having white
space here and just cutting it down so
that it does only take up half the space
I'm definitely open to that that might
look good to maybe I'll try that
michael says since access FES is for
faculty why not have it in the drop-down
I thought this landing page was for
prospective students it is it is for
sure I have no idea why I'm being asked
to put this up here to be honest with
you I don't think it should be there
I think we should have a donate button
there because that's going to be the
only other call-to-action we really want
primarily we want students to apply or
do one of these things and then
secondarily this site is for donors to
see what we're doing here and hopefully
donate so I agree I do not think this
should be there but that's not my call
so maybe I'll bring it up again with my
boss and and see why but you're entirely
right there's yeah there's always been
this weird thing since even before I got
here there's been this weird thing where
it's different departments have tried to
get different content on the site that
has nothing to do with prospective
students and my boss has tried to keep
this site more for prospective students
but it's just been kind of like a back
and forth you know like sometimes and
I'm sure it's like this in other
organizations if somebody high enough up
with enough Authority says to do this
sometimes you just do it you have to do
it so sometimes that happened and you
end up with just a lot of stuff so I'm
really trying to right off the bat make
this as clean and minimal as possible
knowing that there's going to be a big
push for people to want to get their
content on the homepage really high up
so this is one of those cases where
we've already had had that happen yeah
so for now this is here
Harshit says will you use it-- now with
CloudFlare for deployment
then deployment will take ten minutes I
guess it takes you four hours last time
at digitalocean
and I remind you to back up WordPress ok
I did back at WordPress and I installed
I have right now running like that
weekly backups so I did get that up and
running and yeah I I do want to start to
look into different deployment options
hard [ __ ] because you're right it did
take a while to set up all the droplets
before so yeah I'm definitely open to
deployment options it basically it just
needs to be reliable I don't want there
to be any downtime for the users
whenever I need to update things and I
want it to be able to handle all the
users that that were getting set said
Chitra sorry if I'm mispronouncing that
but just said shift row says highly
appreciate what you're doing helped me
to learn a lot of new things oh thank
you for saying that
thanks for watching I'm really glad that
you you're able to learn some things
okay I should say no downtime and
insight you may be using oh yeah you did
say now okay yeah I have used now before
but it's been a WoW I think the last
time I use now to deploy a site was in
the summer of 2017 so it's been a long
time so I want to read up on it more I'm
sure there's a lot more features says
you can scale a little balanced single
command okay cool
all right all right should I'm gonna
read them more up on it this week is
going to be crazy and I'm just going to
be getting ready for my interview on
Thursday and all my presentations so I'm
probably not going to be able to look up
anything I'm just going to be making
small changes based on the audience for
this site
next week I'm hoping depending on all
these go I may have even more
presentations I'm not the one scheduling
these my bosses are scheduling them for
me so hopefully I'll be almost done two
presentations and I can finally get back
to like the normal work that we've been
doing and at that point I really would
like to look into deployment options and
if I can get like a certain like a real
date for when this needs to launch
that'll also make a difference because
then it may or may not be that important
to look into deployment nikki says
adding a subtle shadow to white text on
a bright background makes it more
readable it also makes it pop yeah we I
do need to work on this text a bit to me
I'll try that I usually try to stay away
from from the shadows like like font
shadows but I just kind of don't like
the look of it but I do need to do
something to make it readable okay all
right should I won't forget to check the
Twitter so I got Twitter open right now
on my on my other screen so I won't
forget to check so Nietzsche says just
adding a text shadow and actually put
the text shadow in here all right let's
try this right now and see what the
difference is let's try it out right
here in in dev tools
I'm not seeing a difference right now
but that's probably because whatever is
happening is blending into the shadow
and actually I do so this text shadow
actually matches the shadow I have the
overlay I have over top of this image
exactly so it's both point two I believe
it's both point two so that's why it's
not doing anything but if I lighten the
background but keep the shadow on the
text maybe maybe that would would work
better Joey says you can also try adding
a slightly more tinted box behind the
text and buttons yeah I could do that I
just style-wise I just don't like how it
looks when I do that but I may have to
it it entirely depends on what image we
use and what are the colors in that
image so that's going to be I'm kind of
like shying away from doing too much
because I'm not even sure this will be
the image no one's seen this except for
you all and me no one else at in my
department has seen this so I don't know
if they're gonna like it or not so I
kind of like don't want to try to make
this text do anything with this text
really until I know for sure what's
going to be the image we go with
this is now that you have to do a
presentation everyone's bringing up site
redesign ideas we've been working on
this one where we yeah today yet today
was the day that like you all were just
like hey let's change this let's change
this let's change this I did wonder
about that I'm kind of thinking like
we've had the same thing up here for
weeks and weeks and though it said
anything and now today all of a sudden
it's like yeah let's get rid of all this
stuff I don't know but I I'm messing
around now but I really appreciate all
that stuff like even if you make a
suggestion and I don't end up going with
it I still appreciate it and it still
may change or my design decisions down
the road and other sites or other parts
of the site so and sometimes it has
nothing to do with whether or not your
idea was a good idea it's other things
it's like I know that if I do that
this other person in that I work with is
not gonna like it
so like there's sometimes decisions for
better for worse have to be made like
that I can't always just say like what's
going to be best for the design for the
user or whatever so yeah so please you
know keep the suggestions coming
that's how sites that get better you
know if I do something and it's ugly
just telling me it's ugly you know I
mean you could choose to be nice about
it if you want which would be cool but
even if you're not I'm okay with that
so yeah and like like I said may or may
not include it and that's not a
reflection at all on you or your ideas
there's just a lot of other factors that
need to go into what I work on and when
I work on it so anyway so I think we're
gonna wrap things up soon there's a few
more messages that just came in on live
chat so I'm gonna go through those and
then I'm gonna take a little break here
and we'll see well I may not even have
time to do that second stream like I was
gonna do cuz it's already almost two
will say yeah I don't know if I've time
to do it or not you'll get a
notification though if you're subscribed
to my my channel let's see
Nietzsche says here's the threat of
awesome UI details oh cool thanks sneaky
Biff BAFF says do you use color pattern
sites for designing sometimes I look at
those sites for sites that I make for
the University I I have to stick with
our color palette for university so I
have very little leeway and deviating
from that color palette but for sites
that I'm doing on my own or like a lot
of times clients businesses already have
a certain color palette but if I do have
freedom I do try to go on sites and just
get ideas for different color palettes
and things that's one of the things it
takes me forever like to pick colors but
I mean it's cool why it's kind of nice
to see the combinations but right now
I'm usually like I usually don't have a
say in what colors get used
let's see
all right Nikki I'm checking out that UI
details page right now this is really
cool I like this
yeah there's a lot here it's gonna take
me a while to get through it all but I
this looks awesome okay cool all right a
couple more messages in here
Christopher Brown says have you taken
design classes no I I've taken like no
classes on any like no you know
university classes on any of this so
it's all been I when I was freelancing I
learned what I needed to learn to get
the job done I have done some like
Udacity courses so done free code camp
things but yeah but design wise very
little design stuff I definitely would
would say I'm a developer I have to do
design here when when in because there's
not really a web designer you know here
at the University so I try to use
material design and fall back on that as
much as possible you know because I know
I'm lacking in you know that design
knowledge but yeah so no formal design
classes see Chris's looks great so a
looks great work so far what's your
educational background oh well thank
thanks I'm glad you like it
educational background is I have a
bachelor's degree in business
administration with a specialization in
banking finance and economics other than
that I took some courses in getting a
master's in theology and I never
finished that master's and then pretty
much all of my my learning for becoming
a web developer has been on my own
almost entirely through free resources
the only time I I paid I think I bought
like maybe some udemy courses that were
on sale you know another sale and you
get a course for like $10 I think I did
some of those years ago
but I I did do the reacts nanodegree for
from Udacity but that's that's it I did
coke Academy courses free code camp
stuff trying to think I've tried a lot
of other things but those are the main
ones that I kind of stuck with and did
the most work with those like online
YouTube videos books so usually not like
paper copies of books I like the you
know the online books like like that you
don't know J s series or eloquent Java
scripts you know they're available
online all right cool I've gotten
through everything in the chat now and
yeah I had a good time it was like it
was really interesting to hear all the
opinions on what we're doing and I think
what we have now definitely looks better
than what we had starting out and we got
a little I good good ideas to make it
even better so some of those ideas might
be we might be using them it just kind
of depends on the feedback I get from my
boss and yeah and the feedback I get
from these presentations all right look
I will be back tomorrow I think I got a
double check and make sure what time I
presentation is so I'm not exactly sure
what time I can stream tomorrow but I
think I will have some time at some
point tomorrow to stream hopefully and
until then have a great day